we turn to the phone lines right now and
we're joined by the eddie robinson award
winner for the fcs coach of the year uh
last time he was on um we called him
cody prime um coach of the year uh
jackson state head coach head football
coach and a dear friend uh all full
disclosure uh on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line the one and only dion sanders
how are you coach prime
how you doing my humble host and crew
we're doing great what's up coaching
what's up bro we are doing we're doing
better for talking to you uh so um i i
uh saw that the pro day went down at
jackson state and um uh exceptional
i heard that i heard that
how was it for you dion what was that
great first and foremost i don't know if
they have ever had one i think they did
but uh i think they uh
banished it and got away from it but
just to host a pro day
with several of the schools from the
state was phenomenal
it was
absolutely phenomenal and just being
able to sit there talking to some of the
other head coaches amongst the swag and
some of the other schools in the in the
state it was a great day our kids
competed their butts off uh junior day
we had three dbs run four low four
threes which was crazy
uh it was a very successful day and
we're happy and uh i saw that your
attendance taking skills were were spot
on prime i saw that oh yeah
i was on my game i was on my game
because i told him
you come home i'm gonna call you out and
i did
i did it that makes sense it don't make
sense when i know
you're gonna go to mississippi state
which you should and you're going to go
to ole miss which you should
but you you got to fly in here to get
there
that's the thing i didn't mention rich
you got to fly here to get there unless
you're going private and i don't think
the scouts are going private
[Laughter]
so not only do you have kids that are
worthy of a look-see you're
geographically sound is what you're
saying oh
i saw that i saw that so when you said
you won't forget what do you what does
that mean like um
what what do you we got some dogs we
just had three kids run four threes man
we got dogs coming up you gotta
understand my class it was the first
time last year that was our initial
class those kids are coming up in a
couple years and now you're gonna you
you're gonna want to see them
i just hope i'm not like that but i'm
not petty you know i'm not richard petty
[Laughter]
cause you're the best for my kids i want
the best for my kids of course i know
that but because you know uh del tufo
here was thinking of trying to help you
set up like a vip area for your next um
pro day for those you know who came this
year that they would get more preferred
seating right mike
definitely oh exactly
definitely i even opened up the
cafeteria we fed them all we
treated them really good because we want
them to come back
okay no i i know that i know that and
obviously things are going to get better
and better and better so uh who who did
you see you know from uh either back in
the day that you knew nfl types or
anybody that was there that you you kind
of reconnected with several guys i don't
want to call names because i'm going to
forget somebody then they're going to
get upset and they may not come back
then we're going to have a bigger
problem so i'm not i'm not going to go
down that street but
uh i was happy with the turnout i was
just happy to just be in fellowship with
some of the other coaches like i said
and all the kids were so darn
appreciative that the kid
of the day was kevin green's son
uh i met his his wife
and i met his son uh who who played in
mississippi as well and just you talking
about the most remarkable young man the
most respectful young godly man i blew
my mind man the kid was he performed
well he did a great job but uh you you
talking about a man who's living for his
father that young man is is going to be
successful whatever he endeavors to do
so then what is your you know what is
the game plan here for you to get
jackson state and the entire conference
in which you coach and your kids play
uh uh up uh
i guess in the
conversation with the so-called blue
bloods in your state and and in the
college sport we're doing it rich rich
we're doing it i mean
i think recruiting has gone up i don't
think i know recruiting has gone up
phenomenally well for all hbcus all fcs
schools as well and we're attracting now
the three four and five stars all the
schools are we just got to get our
business practices on point with the
recruiting at the schools the business
practices for the whole campuses and the
whole universities of hbcu's as well as
our fcs schools but everything is
heightened and the lights are shining
even our spring game is nationally
televised this this year on the 24th of
april so
everything is is is getting better and
i'm going to keep on pushing the
envelope interviews like this uh
national interviews on your platform it
everything helps man because these guys
deserve this attention and this focus
and they can play it out play
when you mean business practices what do
you mean prime what do you mean we got
to do better business-wise i mean some
of the things that we're not doing
we're not successful at business-wise
there's no reason why every school
in uh the hbcu community is suffering or
a lack thereof or finances in certain
places how can every darn school uh be
in the same situation that that's not
that's not right then i hear about all
these fortune 500 companies who gave or
who said they gave
i want to make sure that that's correct
did you give and and where did the money
go that you gave or did you have an
earmark for a certain area of concern
what was it because if you give all
these schools that i've heard that
received endowments a hundred million
dollars i think we should be pretty
straight
you know we should be straight so i want
to know is that the truth are you just
saying that because of the pandemic and
and the plight of our people um that has
been challenged tremendously over the
last several years deion sanders here on
the rich eisen show coach of jackson
state football on the program did i see
on that video is that a falcons jersey
that's on the back of your chair chair
yeah it is well you got keen eyes
i look at everything right there it's an
old falcons jersey for you yeah yeah
tracy pearl will send that to me says
coach brown
the great tracy perlman i love it yeah
tracy ptp's is unbelievable she is the
greatest in the nfl she's she's blessed
me let me let me tell you she's blessed
me troy benson uh they're doing
everything they can to help us at hbcus
and in its entirety man and she's
phenomenal
okay i love it i said i noticed that how
are you doing i also saw the video you
put out um you know i i know that you
had some health issues and i saw that
video how are you doing crime i'm not
i'm not high stepping yet
but uh the hand is behind the head
the hand is behind it
i'm moving slowly but surely and i'm
moving briskly i really am i'm i'm i'm
on my elliptical again because i had
lost like 40 pounds richard you know
when i was in the hospital those lost 40
hours that wouldn't eat none but
applesauce lost 40 pounds but i gained
um
50 back
jeez no wow i can't i can't now i can't
i can't fit in my suit so i gotta cut
down i gotta trim down because i had
been able to do cardio because i was
eating everything in the world i was i
mean i was quick i was chris
rockish at one point
hey yeah i was chris rockish so i'm
trying to get to the old prime right now
all right well i mean when you say get
in your suits my suits yeah my seals
don't have bed loops no all my suits are
made for me right so there's a problem
yeah i mean but
you you wear one suit every three years
that i know you know i've i know but i
can't even get into those i can't even
get into those i had a big celebration
that we had a few weeks ago and lay on
my back to get in the pants man
that don't make sense
i mean i i just went past the point of
uh
oh black i was i'm serious i was really
chris brockish and one look i'm proud of
myself lost too much did i ate
everything i can and i fell in love with
those insured drinks i fell in love with
those uh okay um if anybody's out there
listening i'm sure i'm looking for
endorsements
in one stone you know me rich i don't
change
i meant hbcu i need everything i
understood i get it so again i i know
it's about your kids and i i i do want
to just say this though uh ask this
question so no no no seriously so so you
win coach of the year at you know you
win the eddie robinson award while
you're going through all these health
problems i mean is that what you were
doing all year long yeah man it was it
was it was crazy man we couldn't tell
anybody we couldn't say nothing to
anybody
and then uh you know having a couple
couple my digits amputated at the same
time
in uh both of my legs dug out on the
side
my kids told me it looked like the shark
bit me on both sides of my legs
so
that's uh it looks i don't think you'll
see me in shorts at any time anytime
soon you would not see me in shorts i
promise you but i'm better i'm better
but it was a lot going on last season
and now that's the you know what that's
the best secret that i think we ever
kept yeah in life yeah no i know because
you didn't tell anybody you didn't want
it to be i couldn't yeah i could i
couldn't tell anybody that nobody can
play the plum card poor little old me
couldn't do that
well i mean that is something else all
right
so all right what's next for you now
like what what happens now what are you
doing now we're in the spring we're
shoot we we gotta i think we had the top
recruit class fcs again as well and uh
not to mention a guy named travis hunter
i don't know if you know him but uh he's
uh he's phenomenal man this kid made a
couple catches today you know he we had
him starting at the corn on defense
because he's like that but we put him on
offense just just to give him some run
the kid made a couple catches today man
that you just shake your head and just
look at
the person next to you and say oh my god
he he is what what's advertised rich and
uh we got several of those kids that
that can play but he's uh he's he's he's
a phenomenal talent
he's three years and done he will be
fighting for
probably the top three picks in the in
the draft because the kid got it
how many how many uh jackson state uh
kids am i seeing at the combine
uh
three years from now though next year
well next year yeah sure give me next
year how many do you think what do you
think uh we should have a couple next
year for sure at the combine and see
what i'm trying to do i don't like the
separatism rich i don't like you you got
a black combine then you got the combine
combat i don't like that i don't like
that let's just have one combine because
at the black combine you have 54 kids or
something like that 52 kids okay i've
done the math there's only like
four more kids a position or five more
kids in position we got time for five
more kids a position we got time for
five more 40s
you know at each position we got time
for five more bench presses at each
position this easy so instead of having
separate let's just
involve
involve the kids from hbcus
instead of having two dirt separate
combines which
20 percent of the
people that showed up at the real
combine shows up at the hbcu combine
that's not fair
not fair at all
just just thinking aloud that's all no i
know i know i don't know if you saw the
way the combine ended prime but i'll
tell you it's as you know i was there i
did okay where the defensive backs are
done for the day
and
um the young man who caught the last
pass in the drill
snagged it
grabbed it
ran it the entire distance of the field
and from the 25-yard line held it up and
high-stepped with his hand behind his
head
yeah but that's not the most promising
thing that transpires on this day
what what what was that not what i was
talking about i i that was good that was
kind that was that was nice but the
thing that i'm talking about
is the rich eyes and fourth
um i'm doing it in three weeks time
because we're raising a lot more money
for charity now by doing it in los
angeles like we did last year it's a
great setup richard okay
i know it's gonna come okay but go ahead
okay
no no this is a setup i have not run it
yet i have not run it the road
rich because
[Laughter]
because
we're doing it here in los angeles oh i
thought you were going to set me up by
saying you only have three weeks to
train no that's true you didn't run a
great time no that's true
that's true i haven't started training
i'm doing it in about a month that's it
so rich come on man you you come on man
you gotta you gotta have a talk with
your hamstrings man right now you can't
just expect them to get up and go like
they used to
well like they used to is like six seven
i'm like five nine now prime i'm doing
it i'm gonna lose weight
i'm gonna start working out
very soon
rich you don't have but i'm not like
thank you pride
get in this guy's head
he's always in my head
you're always
um today
well it's friday rich you're not
actually no no no no no the two people i
don't want to disappoint the most are
this man and susie my wife there's a lot
of place
if it was susan she would have been
started working out
but do not disappoint him you need to
have started working out like months ago
i understand that i have i have day jobs
i have night jobs and i just got to
focus on this you are working man you're
working there prime i love you thanks
for the time i love you i appreciate you
and your whole crew man the whole staff
i love you guys i wish i wasn't as busy
so that when rich takes his hiatus that
he goes on vacation with the uh with the
kids and and the 15 dogs and uh
that i could come in and stand in for
you but i wouldn't matter because you
yeah you're the best you're the best
guys i appreciate that and now by the
way now that i'm flying around the
country again uh i'm saying hello to all
the security dogs in the airport all the
time
you always enjoyed that when i did that
no i
what what took it over talk you stop you
always kiss him in the mouth
[Laughter]
that's where we divide
you would always say we're going through
security he goes are you going to start
kissing dogs see what you're going to do
get the dogs in the mouth all right
he was not racially it was not racial
because he kissed the black dog
so he is not he is not a racist
whatsoever he kiss all dogs
love you prime thanks for the call i
love you guys take care all right
the one only
actually i think he called it licking
dogs you're going to go up starting
licking dogs
yeah that's a white white guy nothing
guys
nothing like traveling through an
airport with dion
sanders
nothing
everybody knows him nothing yeah i agree
buddy knows him
man woman child race color creed
everybody
and hey he says he he he wants to use
this platform this chair is he knows
that any time he wants
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here